hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
amid the coronavirus pandemic and civil
unrest
law enforcement officials in several u.s
cities are wrestling with a surge in
violent crime
former new york city mayor rudy giuliani
is credited for bringing the crime rate
down in the big apple during his
leadership in the 90s
he discusses what he would do to solve
the spike in shootings and homicides
plaguing the nation
and shares his thoughts on the
contentious house hearing with attorney
general william barr
president trump calling polls suggesting
he's trailing presumptive democratic
nominee joe biden in the 2020 race
fake saying he believes his silent
majority will carry him to re-election
fox news politics editor chris
steierwalt weighs in on these claims
and discusses whether he thinks some
americans are not being honest when
responding to polling
plus commentary by guy benson host of
the guy benson show on fox news radio
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe
on your favorite podcast player by going
to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm maria bartramo i'm greg gutfeld i'm
liz clayman
and this is the fox news rundown
[Music]
wednesday july 29 2020
i'm dave anthony the protests in
portland oregon are now
centered around a courthouse protected
by federal officers and it's turned into
a nightly battle
the democrats want to see portland burn
between now and election day
as a way of defeating trump even if they
kill a few people along the way
and donald trump wants to stop it i'm
lisa brady
at some point in every campaign time
runs out for the person trailing in the
polls
president trump says those polls don't
include the silent majority
but he clearly has some work to do
voters on the issue that matters
overwhelmingly more than any other
voters have determined that he just
can't get it right and i'm guy benson
i've got the final word
on the fox news rundown
more than two months after george
floyd's death during an arrest
sparked nationwide protests against
police brutality
the focus has shifted from minneapolis
where it happened and seattle where
there was that
chop anti-cop zone to portland oregon
[Music]
the protesters there have been out every
night for over two months
it's evolved into a battle with federal
officers deployed to protect a federal
courthouse
people marched to the court try to gain
entrance and have set fires
thrown things used explosives attorney
general bill barr at a house hearing
tuesday said the officers aren't looking
for trouble
but are being targeted some have been
injured
what unfolds nightly around the
courthouse cannot reasonably be called
protest
it is by any objective measure an
assault on the government of the united
states
judiciary committee chairman jerry
nadler scolded barr
saying this confrontation was set up now
you are projecting fear
and violence nationwide in pursuit of
obvious political objectives
shame on you mr barr the mayor of
portland democrat ted wheeler
has been demanding those officers leave
saying he never asked for them in the
first place
and they're making the situation worse a
mayor
that should have been fired ten weeks
ago after the fourth week of riots
for new york city mayor and current
trump attorney rudy giuliani you might
as well just burn your city down
in one day and play the fiddle like nero
if you're going to allow that
well he he himself went out and
supported the protesters
he joined them the other night and he
got tear gassed yeah as well he should
should be arrested actually for doing it
but they don't arrest anybody and if he
got arrested he'd be out in a minute
because comey doesn't hold anybody in
jail
so basically anybody in america that
wants to riot
go to portland you can ride like crazy
you can break open windows you can steal
liquor you can steal dresses you can
steal televisions
and uh even if you get arrested you'll
be out in six hours
meanwhile you got a mayor who's shown
support for you by
rioting with you and trying to attack
the federal building
he's trying to blame it on the federal
government which tells you how pathetic
he is
the federal government didn't arrive
until a week ago this has been going on
for two months
and the federal government is doing just
one thing and one thing alone
they are protecting the federal building
they have vowed to take down
and they have the appropriate law
enforcement officers there to do it
they have not introduced the army that's
another complete lie
by the lunatic left they are using dea
agents
atf agents and other civil law
enforcement organizations
these aren't so exactly who what
organizations
uh mayor what organizations are we
dealing with you talked about the dea
what other i mean there are people
saying that these are secret police that
the president has put in
and they're basically like troops on the
streets that's what a lot of the critics
that's ridiculous they're not secret
police nothing's secret about them at
all
they say they're in plain clothes well
of course they're in plain clothes
my most effective policemen were in
plain clothes policemen are in plain
clothes all over the country
sometimes you want a uniform to deter
somebody from doing it
sometimes if you're dealing with a more
sophisticated problem you want a police
officer that can't be recognized
so he can observe the crime and then
make the arrest this is a complete
democratic hoax but a lot of these
cities
are run by mayors who are democrats and
the mayors of six cities have joined
together they're urging congress
to make it illegal for a deployment
of federal officers like this if the
mayors and the cities don't want that
would be entirely unconstitutional
okay they can go ahead and do it but the
constitution of the united states
allows the president to deploy troops if
he probably finds
a level of of of um suppression that's
going on
and we have it we have a uh kind of
revolutionary situation going on
remember that president eisenhower and
president kennedy did this
during the civil rights movement when
the governors refused to integrate
the schools he sent
he certainly sent the united states
marshals but he also sent in one case
uh reserved offices and it got done
quickly
the democrats want to see portland burn
between now and election day
as a way of defeating trump even if they
kill a few people along the way
and donald trump wants to stop it you
were mayor of course
in the 1990s in new york city if
let's say president clinton at the time
decided to send in
federal officers to new york and you
didn't want them
what would you do he wouldn't do it
he wouldn't do it because i had a very
good relationship with him and he knew
that i knew as much about law
enforcement not just about anybody in
the country
i mean i i was probably the most
experienced person in law enforcement
that's ever been mayor of new york city
and the results show it i reduce crime
more than any other mayor
in any city ever i reduced homicide by
60
overall crime by 67 and i did that in
eight years and it remained that way
under michael bloomberg who was an
excellent successor
he got crime down another 20 so
before this democrat takes over
we were a perfect city in that regard we
were the safest large city in america
we had to work hard to become that i'm i
got us there and bloomberg
kept us there as soon as this
communist inspired mayor
left-wing-inspired mayor
took over the condition started to
deteriorate
the statistics show the same thing in a
lot of major cities
shootings are up 200 percent in new york
in the past month versus last year
murders and shooting incidents have also
surged from chicago
to houston to los angeles in atlanta the
murder rate skyrocketed
240 percent in recent weeks mayor keisha
lance bottoms called it a perfect storm
of distress
in these corona induced tough economic
times yet
overall violent crime is down
year over year according to new york
times report it's five percent lower in
2020 so far
compared to 2019 in 25 large american
cities studied
and back to new york rapes are down
almost 25
there's less felony assault and fewer
robberies in grand larcenies
why all the ups and downs well first of
all there isn't all that much to to
burglarize and rob everything is closed
down and there's not a lot of stuff to
take
the worst thing the mayor did
is release 8 000 people from our prisons
including some rapists
who have committed rape so he's added
instead of adding police he's added
criminals
he already had too few police and too
many criminals plus
the governor passed a no bail law which
means that when the police arrest
somebody they're back out on the street
within four or five hours
so they they have contributed directly
to the out of control situation that we
have
the city did a great job from 1994 until
de blasio
and keeping guns out of the hands of bad
guys the chicago mayor keeps saying that
the
reason for the big rise in shootings
there is that
congress and the president have not
acted
to make gun control laws stricter
so then why is it that we have per
capita four times less murders than her
and we have the same gun control law you
know what the reason is
we aggressively enforce the laws that we
have and we take the guns away
from crooked people so
who is going to comply with a gun
control law
a terrorist an organized criminal
a professional burglar robber they're
going to walk in
and say my name is jon jones give me a
gun
of course not the people that walk in
are the people that legitimate people
but if you are intent on committing
serious violent crimes
and you're in the act of doing it you
don't give a damn about registering
mayor i've seen people refer to these
times
as similar to the late 1960s with
civil and racial unrest and protests in
the streets
do you i wasn't around in the 60s
do you agree that it's similar or not
well i agree i agree that the level of
violence is similar
although i think it is completely
different than the 60s and the 70s
this is a different thing that was going
on in the 60s and 70s they were
protesting a war
that they believe was unjust and they
were protesting
a civil rights situation that they
believed was
unjust and they didn't have a second or
more important agenda so
here instead
there's no war there's really no civil
rights agenda
the agenda if you look at it is purely
social
if you read their platform their agenda
they are doing all this
to do away with the nuclear family to do
away with private education
to gain reparations for black people so
that black people would get a
lifetime income and nobody else would
they're they're involved they're
involved in this to do away with the
police and become their own police
these are people who don't care about
black lives they care about a few black
lives they can exploit
but when a little one-year-old gets
killed or a 19 year old or a woman
and it's just a black person killing a
black person
they turn their back because
it should be this is the movement known
as a very few black lives matter
of course rudy giuliani is one of the
president's lawyers still battling to
keep trump financial records sealed
after a supreme court ruling allowed an
investigation into the president to
continue
there was another hearing in that case
in a lower court on monday
and while it's being led by manhattan
d.a sai
vance giuliani says it's new york
attorney general leticia james pushing
this
this is a complete abuse of power
by an attorney general who was elected
on the promise
that she would get donald trump that's
so
inappropriate to elect a prosecutor to
go get a certain person i can't tell you
and the fact is all of these tax returns
have been there forever
they're in the hands of the irs if
something has to be done to protect the
public
the irs knows a lot better how to do it
without a political motivation
than the highly politicized
new york city criminal justice system
and
what happens though if you lose well
i'll tell you what
she's not going to find anything she's
going to have to make things up
she's going to have to say oh look how
money was spent look how much money was
spent on that but this one
you know that kind of stuff to prejudice
the pose you're not going to find any
just like none of them have found
anything haven't you found the history
to be
they make big boats and then they fall
apart
and then the press doesn't say anything
about it so they can do it again
i mean way back papadopoulos was gonna
break the case open
he's gonna be the key witness against
trump huh
he only met him once knew nothing about
russia
then carter page oh he's gonna be the
big so it turned out they
illegally wiretapped him and they got
nothing he had no connection with russia
i can go on and on you know roger stone
he was going to get the president we got
him now
maybe they should sit back
relax a little and say to themselves
when do we stop
you try five times and you can't find a
crime
maybe you gotta stop maybe he didn't
commit a crime former new york city
mayor rudy giuliani of course one of the
attorneys for president trump
thank you again for joining us thank you
[Music]
this is guy benson with your fox news
commentary coming up
august is just a few days away not much
time for president trump to turn around
sagging poll numbers and approval
ratings for his handling of the pandemic
a man works for us with us very closely
dr fauci and dr burks also highly
thought of and yet they're highly
thought of but nobody likes me
it can only be my personality
president's been calling more attention
to the u.s
investment in fast tracking a coveted
vaccine
while joe biden prepares to announce a
running mate next week
and criticizes the president's decisions
policies
and tone i'm running because
trump is the president and i think our
democracy is at stake
for real the presumptive democratic
nominee has been staying close to home
in delaware and unveiling his economic
recovery plan
planck by plank calling for trillions of
dollars in spending
to address a wide range of issues from
child care and manufacturing
to clean energy and racial inequality
and
he's been leading in poll after poll by
double digits in some cases
though the president and his campaign
question some of the polling methods
and reject those numbers it's hard to be
behind in a race
and we understand that people are going
to attack the polls because
they can't just say well we're losing
and it's not not looking so good right
now
chris stirewalt is the fox news politics
editor also co-host
of the i'll tell you what podcast trump
is in a position
that only a handful of human beings in
history have ever been
which is to say an incumbent american
president
in the modern era who is substantially
behind in his re-election bid
um it's only happened to one person
uh two people exactly like this george
h.w bush and jimmy carter
uh harry truman and gerald ford were
there too
but they were they were uh elevated to
the presidency not elected to it
so he is in a club of only five people
who have ever been in since world war ii
in this space and
it stinks right there's the experience
that
both um carter had
uh and the experience that george h.w
bush had which is
voters come to conclude that you aren't
going to win anyway and it
drops your the enthusiasm of your
remaining supporters
and they say i'm not even going to buy
i'm not even going to bother
um in order for trump to avoid that
outcome he has to keep his base
connected and engaged to get that 40
percent
42 percent of the electorate uh to stick
with him
do we have any sense what's hurting the
president
the most right now is it all about
coronavirus
yeah they blew it and he's trying to get
back on the good foot now
um it they wasted a lot of time in an
election year you just can't waste this
much time
but if you think about the run of time
between
the oval office address that the
president gave
and let's say inject the
uh disinfectant into your lung stuff
that was the wasted time from a
political standpoint
that was where voters were increasingly
increasingly increasingly concerned
about this issue and people were really
upset and the economy was going sideways
everybody was freaked out
and trump couldn't find a way to engage
so
now that he has adopted is trying to
adopt a more
contrite uh partially contrite
and earnest compassionate tone uh
as this goes on and i think when we look
to the events of last week
well in the week before that dump the
campaign manager
cancel the jacksonville rally admit that
things will get worse before they get
better
uh have a sober sighted serious seeming
briefing
this is the setting that could turn the
race around substantially for trump
because right now voters on the issue
that matters
overwhelmingly more than any other
voters have determined that he just
can't
can't get it right he's his his approval
for handling the coronavirus is in the
30s
and he's sunk so while he's out front
sort of trying to shift the tone a
little on that and
and do a better job on that
the campaign ads on his behalf keep
making the argument that the defund
police movement is dangerous that life
will be dangerous if joe biden is
elected
that he'll be a puppet for the radical
wing of the democratic party
is there any evidence that those
arguments are resonating with voters
other than the president's base so these
i have never seen a ad
as scaremongery from a presidential
campaign
this makes the willie horton ad look
like
a peanuts cartoon it is the most
terrifying
a little old lady who looks like she has
just come from a life alert commercial
is about to be murdered by shadowy
figures in the dark
and joe biden doesn't want her to have
the police it is and of course it's
totally fake because biden has said
one million ways that he can he supports
more funding for police
not defunding police he said it in can't
mean he said every way that he can say
it he said it
but they know that for older voters and
that's a that was a big turnaround of
the most recent fox news poll
older voters who because of their
vulnerability to coronavirus
uh had uh turned on the president
um to a pretty surprising degree this of
course voters over 65 are really
important for trump
uh the boomers are are his people
and he was in trouble with them
and i think the focus on law and order
chaos murder death uh and joe biden
wanting you to die uh probably is good
with those voters as is the stuff about
the
preserving confederate heritage and all
of those things i think those are good
that's a good issue set for keeping
older voters
uh on board because if you don't you
know it's it's a damned if you do damned
if you don't for trump
if he doesn't take care of his base and
suck up to his base
then he's not in a position to reach out
to the suburbanites who will decide the
election
on the other hand if he reaches out to
the suburbanites
he'll lose the base and he won't be in a
position to get the election so it's a
really
tough trying to thread that needle
what about the president's and his
campaign's
silent majority claim that they always
bring up i mean i ask with the recent
poll from the cato institute in mind
which showed a high percentage of people
basically afraid to admit
their political views could that add
weight to the
silent majority argument i have i have
not seen that poll
but i can tell you that uh regardless of
what any poll says
obviously americans don't feel
comfortable sharing their political
views with other people have you have
you been on the internet
uh it's not great and um
the the terrible thing about america
today we used to know
you don't talk about religion and you
don't talk about politics you shut up
about that stuff
it makes other people feel uncomfortable
and those are your views
and that's your business in this
performative era
in which we live driven by social media
people just feel this very strong
compulsion
to talk about their political beliefs
and to judge the political beliefs of
others
and so places like you know you have
twitter that just becomes
a sewer where you have this
you know acrimonious space where people
want
to be seen argue with others
and hold each other in contempt so i'm
not surprised that people wouldn't want
to talk about their political views
and more power to them the less
the less people talked about politics
and the more they talked about dogs and
kids and baseball
and everything else the better off we'd
be
is the pool of undecided voters
shrinking yet if you will and who and
who are they has that
changed much since 2016 or are we all
always looking at about the same amount
of undecideds
well something to remember about
undecided voters is a lot of them are
lying
they either don't want to say that
they've decided they don't want to say
who they've decided
uh or they just want you know i don't
know yet because maybe they think it's
better to wait till the end
um i you know these a lot of these
voters are leaning one way or the other
when you get down to it though you're
talking about an undecided vote of like
four percent probably three or four
percent and
those are probably a lot of people who
aren't going to vote right those are
those
those are probably if you haven't made
your mind up if you really haven't made
your mind up
you're probably not going to vote i
wonder if we could
leave this on a positive note for either
side
and that is to say that it's you know
less than 100 days
on the one hand it feels like time's
getting short but then it's
there's still time is the bottom line
right
right well you know we um
we were talking before about carter and
bush
ford and truman have another story to
tell about incumbents who are way behind
uh at this point and that is
ford staged an astonishing rally uh he
got
very close at the end he was way behind
but a couple of things happened
republicans united
ronald reagan who had challenged ford
came in
and uh in the the convention and
strongly endorsed ford the party healed
it provided great momentum going forward
ford got out there
and ran like crazy and also people came
to have doubts about a very unknown
character
and an unusual political character jimmy
carter
harry truman uh at this point was so far
down
uh that pollsters were stopping polling
because it what was the point and he
rallied so hard because what he did was
similar
he was in trouble because uh bigots in
the south
who were angry at him for
integrating the armed forces had bolted
and formed
the dixiecrat party uh strom thurman who
would go on to become a republican
was their nominee so you have all these
bigots enthusiastic bigots who are angry
at truman
and they're going to defect and it looks
like truman's going to lose the south
but truman is able to get those voters
get not those voters back but convince
enough
less bigoted southern voters to come in
he keeps virginia he keeps north
carolina he keeps florida
uh he keeps georgia i believe
but he does lose south carolina alabama
mississippi
and louisiana but wins the rest of the
south wins enough to win the presidency
so for trump he could sort of think of
that as his suburbs right
he's just got to get enough of those
suburban voters to say
i don't like him i'm bothered by him and
i don't think he's a good leader
but i'm not going to vote for a democrat
i know what i'll get with taxes i know
what i'll get with spending i know what
i'll get on the courts
so i'm just gonna i'm gonna stick with
trump but that depends on
him having enough self-control to keep
it
basically uh between the lines for for
another 90 some days fox news politics
editor
chris stirewalt thanks so much for your
time
you bet
[Music]
fox news radio on demand on the fox news
app download the app and just click
listen
when you swipe left you can listen to
your favorite fox news talk shows
live swipe right for the latest fox news
radio newscasts on demand
fox news radio and the fox news app
download it today
subscribe to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com
it's time for your fox news commentary
guy benson
what's on your mind president donald
trump recently sat down with chris
wallace of fox news sunday for a full
broadcast
hour of challenging probing questions on
a variety of topics wallace was on the
top of his game
and gave trump a really tough interview
since then i've been making the case
that joe biden ought to do the same
what's good for trump ought to be good
for the man who wants trump's job but on
sunday
chris wallace said this this week we
asked the biden campaign for an
interview and they said the former vice
president was not available i'm glad
they'll persist and i hope at some point
the biden campaign relents
american voters deserve to hear biden
pressed on issues
with follow-ups there hasn't been a lot
of that and the idea that biden is not
available
doesn't pass the smell test the guy is
nothing but available with plenty of
free time down in the basement
disengaging and sleepwalking to victory
may be a sound strategy we'll find out
but the american people deserve better
and joe biden
should sit down with chris wallace this
is guy benson
host of the guy benson show
[Music]
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast
at foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes